can oh dude thank you Sam I've been
waiting so long to hop on here and talk
to you
like
sorry um so uh I'm a I'm a Christian
like um I kind of like I grew up as a
Christian and then like you do martial
arts what kind of kick is that bro shoot
oh that's was in high school I'm a
professional kickboxer damn bro in fact
here you know what hold on bro one
second shoot you can ask your question
but I want to do something hold on goad
ask your question okay okay um yeah so
um I have a couple questions but like
the first one I'll start off with this
is like like um my friend he's kind of
like an atheist he's kind of like he
kind of atheist or whatever and like one
of the like whenever we like get into
debates um one specific one he had asked
me that I never really had the answer to
was like he's like oh like if God is so
good and all this D like why does he
just like Satan like run around and do
his thing like why doesn't he just like
destroy him I'm kind of just like oh
like my kind answer is always just like
you know Free Will and everything you
know what I mean like it's like the
it's like the um the the opposite of
good you know evil da d da like you know
you have to like let the you have to
like evil have to exist if there's gonna
be good all right so coming back to okay
you said that you someone brought an
objection about Satan yeah he's like
he's like why was if God is so good and
all this he's so powerful why would he
just let Satan just like run around and
do whatever he wants like why does he
just destroy him and I was like well
it's like well that is that's actually
proof that God is good even to his
enemies
H so if God is so good why does he let
Satan run around because he's so good
that even God's Satan to exist for a
season showing you that God even shows
compassion to his enemies just like the
Bible
said here let me show you right okay
back okay his question is because he's
nervous because he's with the greatest
kickboxers has ever seen that's why like
speak slower son if God is so good why
does let Satan run around that actually
proves the goodness of God ironically so
it backfires why it shows that God is
even kind compassionate loving to his
enemies and he allows them to continue
for a season showing that he's even
compassionate and patient with his
enemies but none will escape the day of
judgment here let me show it to you bro
shoot man the guy thought he had you
huh say dude you just provve that God is
good more off fact right shoot man like
you go damn
Gina all right here Matthew 5 43- 48 43
you ready all right uh ready I'm reading
it for you I'll read it you just pay
attention Okay you ready ready you have
heard you have heard that it was said
You shall love your neighbor and hate
your enemy but I say to you love your
enemies bless those who curse you do
good to those who hate you and pray for
those who spitefully use your and
persecute you that you may be sons of
your father who's in heaven for he makes
his son rise on the evil and on the good
and sends Reign on the just and on the
unjust so he says that God the Father
even shows love to his enemies by
allowing them to benefit in Joy his
Provisions right for if you love those
who love you what reward do you have do
not even the tax collectors do the same
and if you greet your brothers only what
are you doing more than others do not
even the TA colors do so therefore be
perfect even as your father who's in
heaven is perfect so wait by God not
wiping out Satan but allowing to exist
that actually proves that God is good
and loving and compassionate because
even shows compassion and is patient
with even his enemies including
Satan and here Psalm 1458
to9 so ironically that actually proves
the opposite point doesn't it and you
guys listening right you guys learning
how to answer these Psalm
14589 the Lord is gracious and full of
compassion right yes s anger and great
in Mercy the Lord is good to all and he
has compassion and his compassion is
over all his Works wait is Satan one of
his
works that God creat Satan yes he
created to be S but did he create him
yeah he created him well it says that
God shows compassion to all his works if
Satan is one of his works then he shows
compassion to him
and and it's even good to Satan show you
how evil and wicked Satan is that God
even shows him compassion and shows him
kindness and is good to him and the way
he repays God Is by opposing him
interesting andigo if I explain to you
why they were bound is because they
cohabited with the human race and
contaminated the human seed oh everyone
else got it ironically folks your Bible
shows that by tolerating Satan God is
showing him compassion kindness and
patience because God shows even mercy
and compassion to his
enemies showing you that Saint deserves
the Wrath that will come upon him for
responding to God's patience and
kindness to him the way he does let me
give you one more okay everyone got
it are you learning guys that by the way
for those of you learning and actually
listening doesn't this blow you away how
marvelous your Bible is how deep your
Bible is and how gloriously beautiful
the god of the Bible is he has all the
answers now let me read one more for you
Luke 6 32-36 right all right and then
you can ask the other question as long
as you don't panic right
okay for if you love those who love you
what thanks do you receive so Satan
doesn't love God but God still loves him
as a creature that he made
that's why he shows him kindness for
even Sinners love those who love them
and if you do good to those who do good
to you what thanks do you receive for
even Sinners do the same God is a
perfect being and his love is perfect
and his kindness is perfect and he
demonstrates how loving kindness by
being loving and kind to his enemies
hold on yes who's knocking on my door
hold
on yes who is this
hello can I help you we're on a live
stream okay uh yeah my I forgot my car
is an SUV so I don't know now hey uh it
keeps going off but that means if I go
out we're gonna lose connection hold on
Buddy so guys okay so let me finish the
verse all right and then we're going to
head out and I may lose connection
temporarily I'm G to go off camera but
that's okay guys I may lose connection
just take it easy so you're going to
stay and hold the fort right uh yep for
a you love those who love you what
thanks do you receive watch here for
even Sinners love those who love them
okay I'm gonna go off camera for a
second this is this is why being single
sucks are you laughing at me or with me
bro oh with you with you with you with
you but I got a lot first bro
shoot all right here now let's read so
if God only loved those who loved him
then he'd be no better than Sinners
right correct all right and if you do
good to those who do good to you what
thanks do you receive for even Sinners
do the same so if God was only good to
those right who are good to him he would
be no better than Sinners right correct
all right so if God is perfect and his
love is perfect and he proves that his
love is wrong and if you lend to those
from whom you hope to receive what
thanks do you receive if I only lend you
because I know you return it that means
no better than Sinners even Sinners lend
to Sinners receive as much in return but
love your enemies do good and lend
hoping for nothing in return guys let's
practice what I preach lend to someone
that you know won't give you back that's
how God is then your reward will be
great you'll be the sons of the highest
for he is kind to the unthankful and the
evil be therefore merciful as your
father's merciful so in other words god
is perfect and a perfect God will love
and be kind to his enemies the very fact
that he tolerates Satan the very fact he
allows Satan to exist shows that God is
even loving and kind to
Satan his enemy now guys I'm going to
lose connection in a minute can you hear
me now I can hear you
now yeah for a while okay my car is
okay okay now we got the answer to the
first question